here now is retired acting ice director
and fox news contributor tom homan tom
good morning to you let's talk about
problem and then solution here's problem
take a look at the rio grande valley i
mentioned some of these numbers but this
is in particular the rio grande valley
2020 to 2021
this year almost 48 000 encounters a
year ago 17 000. as i looked through tom
the various sectors the rio grande
valley's up what is that 175 percent
yuma by the way up massively how is it
in by the way all border sectors up
across the board but some more so than
others how is it that the illegal
immigrants focus on some areas or why in
some areas versus others
well the criminal cartels pay attention
to the border patrol resource and where
they're at and and let me set something
straight the 173 000 is that may be an
accurate number on encounters but that's
not the total number of illegal
crossings in the united states one thing
this administration is doing they're
playing a shell game they'll say okay
the numbers went down from 212 to 180.
yeah the number of arrests went down but
the number of got aways increased
because what the border patrol is doing
like they did in yuma last week they had
so many people crossing the border in
yuma that there wasn't any bourbon
religions on the line they're all
processing people and when they do that
more people will come across in godaways
so let me be clear
less encounters means more gallaways and
and you talk to bournemouth on the
ground they'll tell you that so the
numbers are not decreasing you're
talking about 1.8 million encounters
under the president of president biden
you add to that over 400 000 got away as
well we're talking about 2.2 to 2.3
illegal entries under this president on
purpose because they have purposely
unsecured this border
so tom you and i both mentioned yuma by
the way it's worth putting that to
numbers a year ago it was something like
a thousand encounters in yuma it's up
above 20 thousand it's up two thousand
percent in that sector but i wanna focus
on texas for just a moment tom so
governor abbott says the state is gonna
take over building some sections of the
border wall
now i believe he said they can start
with a 1.7 mile stretch that the state
owns land that the state owns what what
will
texas be able to accomplish either
through private land or state-owned land
in recreating the border law wall how
patchwork what will that look like tom
look at for every model wall they put up
lives are saved and there'd be less uh
uh illegal immigration less illegal drug
flow look texas is going to use their
land so they can build this while
they're using the same model trump
administration use so they can build on
their own land no problem they also have
ranchers donating land because they're
sick of this uh what's going on but
another thing we need to be
reminded of is that the the federal
government seized a lot of texas land
and rancher land last year to build a
wall or under eminent domain now since
this administration has chosen we're not
going to build that wall then that land
needs to be returned to the ranchers
need to be returned to the state of
texas so we can build a wall another
thing i noted when i'm watching uh that
was what's unfolding down there is you
got tens of millions of
materials sitting on the ground being
rotting that the taxpayers already paid
for but they won't sell it to texas to
put the money back in the taxpayer
conference they're going to let it sit
there and rot taxpayer
purchase materials while while the
governor has to buy new materials to
build his wall this this this is just a
ridiculous strategy from this from this
administration to let that happen
yeah that's that's fascinating texas
apparently is using the same contractor
as well so the same contractor could
pick up the same supplies and start
building again on texas land but no you
must buy new supplies tom homan thanks
for all like always for putting into
context for us
thanks for having me well all right